welcome to this video play Killy this
guy is 2300 and he always plays the
Dutch against me two times already and
play turned it in a very weird fashion
so let's see how he does this time don't
really remember how we did it we had
something similar and I we had one game
yeah we also had something with this I
don't get it what is this guy doing 95
isn't this terrible for black I don't
know maybe I'm just too too conservative
of a player to to get this let's say 95
so what now mmm troops is six probably
from Janet layers and what now night a
for Bob Bishop f4 Bishop f4 probably
yeah but this is not going to end well I
have a three-night a 495 yeah anyway
don't tell me you take on me too now
yes he does Wow
create five the only thing that is kind
of irritating I would love to Castle if
I get castling and then this game is
essentially over but it's not that easy
if i play c4 yes Queen 85 check yeah i
assume is doing this and what now
exactly how to really punish this maybe
crc for he gives us check mmm they don't
really want to move the king it's there
some way around that starting with Queen
d2 94 still haven't see for maybe do
this not quite sure this is the best
down
is completely insisting on never
developing is really cute I thought is
six maybe some will see for Bishop c4
then a four hmm or a 484 lets me castle
so let's do it I really want to Castle
threatening look be one I can just take
made on this heaven 197 is that stronger
all right let's take yes to go keep
Queenie seven looks fairly fatty weird
c6 and I would you wanna Scott
threatening c6 yeah so what now I can
take this simply on stored c6 still c6
actually is working he takes the bishop
it's made into let's do that should
always be sure to be seven strong i can
still go queen d7 queen g7 king of aid
only move 91 c7 saying things
okay just play that first and ask
questions later but just take f7 here or
is this is there something better really
cheek c7 I would like to take c7 but I
don't see how it wins take group the
eight take things push it back c7 mother
might be winning but I'm not entirely
sure not entirely sure now you can just
stick with the king that's simple just
so simple and now my bishop hangs yeah
that was not good by far not optimal by
far not it should have been over long
ago
and I can just play this and rook c8
this is the problem time warning awful
simply awful let's go to have three then
now that's terrible that that should
have been over by move 20 and I didn't I
didn't kill it off yeah actually suspect
that he is deliberately playing this
badly and homes to for straight people
but they don't win and even though we
place as bad because well nobody really
yeah i don't know i don't see any decent
player playing like that and he has a
pretty high rating I unfortunately
failed this time check check he actually
screwed this end game up as well but not
not sure how bad it is time already now
37 seconds it's quite a bit of time a
force no move now and check
wow black resins geeky went from a
winning end game 2 lost end game in no
time ok well the position after the
opening opening is of course a complete
win but I didn't I didn't finish it off
so let's see how to finish it off
somewhere around here I mean see high of
tea eggs Queen B 4 is 1 win why exactly
Queen B seven maybe Queen B 7 hmm ok i
did that is probably not bad oh well
it's just plus 1 just plus 1 and this is
this is like plus 3 how exactly is it
working creamy Sam let's say it is this
i go here no I go here we ate looked you
up to one nail care that is indeed
Winningham and this also roped in one
jigs this is a nice move that's
difficult to see if beforehand there
must be made I mean he has nothing
developed this is the whole disaster him
and now ok I can take I can take off
course g5 which I saw it and I thought
this this is somehow somehow work but it
didn't it really didn't it is just just
not that grade Bishop g3 but I couldn't
really believe it and here i'm just-just
losing would you one near this is the
lost end game just like that but you
completely miss plated so how exactly
now this is probably not so bad three
but I can take F too huh I'm just
blundering after yeah there was a really
bad game yeah after he didn't take your
time back in business somewhat and he
could have just taken it yeah I now yeah
I'm much better yeah he just gave me
this part for no reason something like
this again with this idea the party are
still very dangerous that still wins for
black check check Joe here white winsome
check now you know Jerry really all
pawns yeah a very bad game from from
both sides really ok well guys thanks
for watching